I just can't shake this feeling, something's off
there's a very good reason Director Mace is never too far away from that Briefcase
sniper, get down!
everybody hold on!
Aida no!
I need answers
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my episode 9 episode 10
promo video so I'm combining those two things.
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen episode
9 yet.
There is a new round of the aHulkbuster giveaway
going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Previous winners announced at the end of the
video so be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything will start
with episode nine top 10 Easter eggs all that
stuff then I'll do the stuff in the promo
for the next episode.
For episode 10, so number 10 ghostwriter and
Eli Morrow are lost in the dark dimension
or whichever dimension they been pulling energy
from the way their hinting is that is the
hell of the Marvel universe.
The only thing that's keeping me from saying
that it's definitely the dark dimension is
the fact that the spirit of vengeance said
there's no way that I'm going back and what
happens is is when souls get pulled of the
dark dimension and co-opted by Dormammu they
sort of get turned into mindless once they
have like one giant I the middle of their
face, they sort of stopping people, so it's
not like you can come back from that.
So the other option is help Mephisto's domain
which actually has like real souls the could
potentially escape it all goes into ghostwriter's
origin story from the comics the Johnny blaze
ghostwriter who we know past his spirit of
vengeance to this version of ghostwriter.
So they're both stuck in that other dimension
for now but you have to remember that Eli
Morrow still infused with all that energy
they're both still tied to the dark cold the
dark cold is still a very big Macguffin the
season so it all come together by the season
finale meaning the ghostwriter will be back.
So number nine ghostwriter.
Probably not coming back for little while,
just because the dark cold is something they're
going for but until Doctor Radcliffe gets
it in things go completely sideways we probably
won't see ghostwriter again because you see
the pics now mad scientist gets his hands
on the dark hold something terrible happens
that provides the opportunity for ghostwriter
to come back number 880 goes full old Tron
an open revolt and it's the start of Max 80s
robot uprising movie jokes, so he made a sick
burn on Terminator salvation like over going
to make and watch all the Terminator movies
even salvation I guess that depends on how
bad you think that one was theirs the maximum
overdrive joke when the Queen jet starts going
after them.
That was actually a Stephen King book, but
it's about cars that come alive and start
chasing people down to kill them and then
at shopping mall joke at the very end which
is like a B movie about a bunch of robots
at a mall you can imagine killing everybody
pretty much everybody in the episode got there
robot uprising joke but Mac had all the good
movie references number seven BJ in a deer
the Inhumans in the cocoon wakes up we learn
he's the senator's brother and we get there
Backstory using flashbacks to the MCU.
We learned that they lived in New York and
their mother was killed during the should
Towery invasion.
So the senator starts talking about a promise
that they made each other either one of them
was compromised by an alien virus that they
would take care of you know kill the other
person like put them down before the affliction
took them.
So you learn why she hates Inhumans so much
because she equates that with her mother's
death this big disaster aliens taking over
she's like we gotta get rid of them.
She really doesn't know what's going on the
Inhumans are kind of like an offshoot of humanity.
They have dormant genes that are awakened,
so becoming an in human sort of like devolving
just like Vijay goes through a couple different
evolutions of the episode, but number six
the director is forcing Daisy to work with
him.
Stay close because of the very public thing
that happened with the ghostwriter incident
the director himself is still very mysterious.
He's the patriot from the comics who took
up the mantle of Capt. America next week's
episode is actually called the patriots was
that she can explain some of the secrets that
he's keeping because right now it seems like
he's in Inhumans, but he's not an in human
in the comics and he never got the super soldier
serum.
So he just took up the mantle of Capt. America
but he was still a normal person, but really
the real drama is the May life model decoy
in what she's going to do because she seems
really benign.
She's just being uses this tool to get her
hands on the dark cold number five, eight
as full-blown Terminator assault to get the
dark hold on the shield base so this was so
greatly.
She eventually gets her hands on the dark
cold she gives this big speech about the things
that the dark cold is revealed to her it revealed
desire it revealed all these emotions.
So this is very Pinocchio no strings on me
old Tron type situation, which is that she's
about to leave doors open boom, Mac answer
with the shotgun.
Next, it was a great way to go down just chop
that had right off, but because of the twist
at the end you have to wonder whether or not
she actually acquired human emotion because
Doctor Radcliffe is treating these life model
decoy is is sort of disposable toys and he
just makes is many as he wants.
So will see that doesn't bite him in the ass
by the end number for the senator tries to
kill her brother using the watchdogs his powers
activate we learn he has a version of superspeed,
but he's not really based on any of the Inhumans
from the comics video remains to be seen he's
going through a second evolution, so that
might change them into something a little
more familiar but he himself is someone that's
original to the TV show he's not named after
a comic book character number three we learn
the senator is either working with the watchdogs
are working for them.
Their boss is someone named the superior who
they keep using male pronouns to describe.
So it sounds like a man in it sounds like
based on the set up.
It's gonna be either someone that we've met
before on the TV show some villains will reveal
himself like oh my God I can't believe it
was that person or is going to be a big comic
book character but there is somebody from
Marvel comics history name Jon Gallagher whose
alias is superior.
So he might be the person on agents of shield
just like another big boss that they haven't
revealed yet.
You know you have like your Darth Vader reveal
then eventually you find the Emperor is really
behind it all.
So this is like a very Star Wars type reveal.
So will meet him eventually but they're just
setting him up.
Is this really mysterious powerful person,
but number two Doctor Radcliffe reveals he
was behind everything he orchestrated Ada's
actions making you wonder if she actually
really was senti and if she is being honest
when she said the dark cold shoulder all those
emotions, but here's the thing that I like
the actor Jon Hannah is playing him is this
crazy mad scientist he is not evil he wants
to help humanity.
So in a very classic mad scientist twist,
he just overreaching like he just doesn't
care what the consequences are he's not thinking
about how it might go sideways.
He just thinking of the amazing things that
they'll be able to do with the dark cold which
means that it is going to blow up in everyone's
faces in the best possible way it can be so
WTF it'll be great if you thought.
Eli Morrow had crazy plans for the dark hold
what Doctor Radcliffe has planned is way bigger
he'll he's trying to evolve humanity in the
same way that the Terrigen Mists of all humanity,
we know the dark hold itself was created by
an elder gods to thought to sort of troll
anyone that was brave enough to read it.
So he really just trying to create chaos,
but it really does have the knowledge of the
universe inside so if you can control it like
if you were Doctor strange you might actually
be able to make use of it, you can just bed.
Nobody on the show is going to be able to
handle whatever it is they pull out of the
dark cold is always going to blow up in their
faces and I did like Coulson's tease that
they were taking the dark hold to someone
that was capable of disposing of it.
They were sort of teasing.
Doctor strange somebody with magical abilities
that could contain the dark hold because it
can't be destroyed.
You can only hope to contain it number one
WTF of course is Vijay in a deer going through
his second evolution.
So he goes into the cocoon me that's can heal
him he'll emerge.
It'll probably be something like when Quicksilver
from the comics took in the Terrigen Mists's
when a normal person with in human DNA takes
in the Terrigen Mists it unlocks their abilities.
They gain some special power when someone
already has powers like somebody with the
X gene Orsino to somebody as a metahuman takes
in the Terrigen Mists they get powers that
are way off the charts crazy.
They might choose to use him in the Ulysses
marvels Civil War to type way during Civil
War to.
Ulysses is a new Inhumans that seems like
he has the ability to predict the future but
it continues to evolve like he gets more and
more powerful until he can predict the future
in the entire multi-verse.
So people get really confused.
He starts saying all these things are going
to happen.
He shows them visions of what might happen,
but it turns out that those are things that
might happen in other realities.
So he becomes so powerful that the cosmic
entity paternity comes down and welcomes him
to the fold, and he becomes a cosmic entity
himself like that's how powerful he gets.
So that also might be what's happening with
the Vijay character you guys can let me know
what you think is good happened when Vijay
comes out of the cocoon how powerful the think
he's going to be next big thing the promo
for the next episode so this is all about
the patriots Backstory in the comics he was
the third version of Capt. America they've
tease that he might get to use Capt. America
shield on the TV show like the clip says Gen.
Talbot is suspicious of him.
There's a reason he always travels with that
briefcase.
So, were gonna learn what that is.
Were gonna learn how he got his powers.
Congratulations to this week's hope Buster
giveaway Arab into shock.
Please private message me on the back and
my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll announce the winner when I post
my next agents of shield video next week next
week will be just like normal because all
the other shows that would normally air on
Tuesday arm back for like another two weeks.
So next shield video will come next Wednesday
big news.
Spider-Man was just confirmed for Avengers
infinity war.
We have an idea of what the big roster is
going to be so do a video for that tonight.
There's also some Star Wars episode 8 plot
teasers that the director was dropping so
that will be next after Spider-Man while you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
to learn all about Thor Ragnarok Avengers
infinity war and the death of the Marvel universe
and you can click here for all about why everyone's
freaking out about the Batman movie and Justice
league thank you so much watching everybody
high five I'll see you guys tonight!